hey guys so the other day I hung out
with pretty much the coolest girl ever
how many of your friends have a video
camera in the necklace and an LCD screen
on their back
yeah I don't think any of them do Barbie
and I we had a great time we went to the
beach
we ate sushi didn't we have so she was
really good wasn't it it was good
maybe I'll just show you the video from
our day I know Barbie I'm almost ready
you always look part of it little girl
like me fix a lot Kyle the guy does it
takes a skilled artist to make a sushi
but it also takes a lot of practice to
eat sushi properly watch and learn
Oh Barbie this is the life sun sand all
these cute boys to look at Oh
looks like that hottie over there wants
to play frisbee with me this will
probably happen like 50 more times today
okay toss it over here I'll toss it back
I'll be my number is your obviously
Florrick my entire face is broken
hey girl does dorky dance messy girl
eating sushi girl's face vs. frisbee
what is this these all have like a
million views but luckily we can review
all of your footage and edit out all of
the embarrassing stuff unless of course
all you shot was embarrassing stuff
thanks Barbie
maybe I'll repay the favor in one of my
videos thanks so much for watching my
video I hope you guys liked it I had so
much fun shooting it except the sushi
part because I actually don't like sushi
so that was that was a little rough
anyway there's a fun contest going on at
barbie comm slash video real contest
where you can get a chance to win an
HDTV a blu-ray disc DVD player a year of
Netflix and surround sound system sounds
pretty sweet just create your own a day
in Barbie's fab life with your video
girl Barbie doll and enter at Barbie
calm / video real contest be sure to
check out the last video that I did with
video girl this was actually really fun
it was a tour of Mattel and you got to
see how they actually make the video
girl Barbie doll which is pretty cool